foreign
[Silence]
for the day of the great appointment
taken from the traditions
and ways of the best of servants the
prophet muhammad
honestly for a person to
love something or for a person to love
someone they must know them
and this is why allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
dedicates so much of the quran or one of
the reasons why allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala dedicates so much of the quran
to his names and attributes so much so
that it is said
that one-third of the quran is strictly
and explicitly about the names and
attributes of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
why is that well one of the reasons
is that as ibn al-qaeda
said so eloquently whoever learns
allah's names
and attributes whoever understands
allah's names and
attributes and studies them and
understands them will in spite of
himself
come to love allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
likewise is the issue with the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
alaihi wasallam
as we know in the narration which is in
the prophet
[Silence]
he said none of you will truly believe
until i am more
beloved to him and more dear
than his children his
parents and all of the people
now how does a person achieve
this legislative love for the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam
obviously one of the prerequisites to
such
love is that an individual know who he
is
and this is a problem that we have
that a person a person's claim to
something does not necessarily mean
that the claim is valid what does that
mean
well in order for a person to
worship allah to love
allah then a person must know who allah
subhanahu is
and that an individual must know who
allah is
through the texts of allah meaning he
tells us
who he is if you assume
about allah subhanahu wa
then you may end up worshiping
a figment of your imagination
and this is what allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala refers
[Silence]
a group of people that will come to meet
him on the day of resurrection
that manifests for them will be from
allah that which they did not expect
why is that because they assumed and had
presuppositions
about allah that were inaccurate
presuppositions of forgiveness
presuppositions of
favor right as allah mentions in the
quran
that the disbeliever this
disbelieves and belies the hereafter and
that there will be a judgment yet he
says
and if i am returned to my lord indeed i
will have there
a great reward awaiting me
and we see this all the time someone
will die someone will pass away
and then people will say i am sure that
he's in heaven now looking down on us
and all of these things
this is because they are worshiping a
figment of their imagination
has told you something about himself or
unless the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam has told you something about
allah
then you cannot suppose it you cannot
pre
suppose that allah is or is not
subhana and this is why the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make dua and say
[Arabic recitation]
i am unable to adequately
describe your you
and call your praises you are rather as
you have praised yourself
he would make in his dua
and so a person may spend his life
assuming that allah is or is not
not having any authority from allah
to such assumptions and then when he
meets allah
he realizes that it was not a law that
he was worshiping rather it is
something that his mind has conjured up
for him
likewise the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
if an individual wishes to follow the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he must learn who he is
and there is not a human being that has
ever walked this earth
has been more documented and more
meticulously
studied than the prophet muhammad
hands down there is not a person
who has ever walked on this earth or
ever will
that has been more meticulously studied
and whom
whose life has been more
detailed and preserved than the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
every single thing that he did
said did not do refrain from doing
reactions all the way down to what he
would wear
what he liked and what he didn't like
what his diet was like
what his sleep patterns were like
even how he would breathe
and how he would walk and what his voice
sounded like
and this is not by accident this is an
order that
nations that will come after
meaning meaning generations
for thousands of years we'll be able to
look back
and see who it is they're following
and a person must make certain that it
is the prophet muhammad that he is
following
and not a figment of his imagination
whom he has conjured up
based on presuppositions of how the
world
should be and this is very important
so it's very important that we take
the descriptions of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam from the
people of knowledge from the scholars of
islam
who have understood the narrations of
the prophet and the companions
very well and have
looked over them in a way to be able to
see what is and what is not
this is not some small feat this is a
big issue
for a person to be able to to be able to
look at
all of the sunnah that is available to
him
and see the big picture to see
the woods to see the trees for the woods
as it were
and the reason for that
is that we may find isolated narrations
that mention a particular thing but are
not indicative
of a habit of the prophet
and so people that have
an illness in their heart or people that
wish to
make the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam into something they
find more desirable they will twist
these
isolated narrations isolated statements
isolated incidents
to fit their particular agenda and they
may be doing it
unconsciously as well and it's foolish
for us to
assume otherwise and so
we have instances in which the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said or did something but this is not
indicative
of a particular
this is not indicative of a habit that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
had
this is not indicative of
a particular methodology that the
prophet salallahu sallam had
there are narrations in which the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was narrated to have
wrestled with
rukana
was known from amongst quraish as one of
the
strongest men around
and there's not anybody who would
wrestle with rokhana
except that rokana would pin him down
and so it's narrated that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
accepted the challenge of rokhana
to wrestle under the condition that if
he were able to wrestle him that he
would accept islam
and as the narration mentions that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam did
wrestle with
and did in fact pin him resulting in the
acceptance of islam of
urukana but does this mean that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would go around wrestling
all of the time with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam turned
himself into a professional wrestler
or should we if we have a fancy for
wrestling use this as an
evidence that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
loves wrestling
this is one example but it's something
that's very important for us to
understand
this is an isolated incident
it does not mean that we now
are to transform the prophets of allah
in our minds into a professional
wrestler
who would spend hours and days
wrestling and and observing such things
this is incorrect
likewise there are incidents in which
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
if it was very hot and he was amongst
friends
close companions that a part of his
upper thigh may be exposed
this is an isolated incident or a
collection of isolated incidences
does this mean that the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would endorse walking
around
with short shorts with the knees always
with the upper thighs always exposed for
men
the answer is no we do not extrapolate
from this
a pattern this is something which is an
exception to the rule
right and on and on the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam may have
repaired one of his shoes
perhaps he had sown one of his garments
it does not mean that he was a
seamstress
does not mean that he was a shoe
repairman
right and it doesn't mean that his wives
did not serve him in that capacity
this is an isolated incident we are not
to turn the prophet sallallahu
alaihi into a maid to his wives
this is an incorrect understanding of
the sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
yes he would not
reject the request of anything requested
of him
sallallahu and he would
act in the capacity of a very
affectionate husband
but this does not mean that his wives
were absolved of responsibilities
towards their husband
as many people to use these
narrations
as evidence for such conclusions
and and so on and so forth and so
it's important for us not to make
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
into something that we find more
palatable
that we learn who he is according to the
most correct sources
and that we understand those sources
based on the understanding of the
scholars of islam
the most prominent of them
being the companions
we are to understand things in their
proper context
this is something that i wanted to
mention before we continue
because it's something that is
inconstant
it is a constant mistake and a constant
regretfully being that
information is so readily available
and so much at the tips of
the fingers of any and all of us for
that matter
a little bit of knowledge is dangerous
as the adage says and that is that
we are to be very careful that we always
understand this information
from the quran and sunnah based on the
understandings of the scholars of islam
for
the past 15 centuries
we do not need anybody to come along and
bring us new understandings
we don't need anyone to come along and
bring us new methodologies or
uncover some newly invented matter
for us to jump on its bandwagon
our religion is a religion of strict
traditionalism
that traditionalism is open-ended to
accommodate
a a plethora of circumstances
however that is to be controlled
or that proverbial vowel is to be
controlled by the scholars of islam
and we have discussed previously the
position and the role that the scholars
of islam play
in this in this nation this great nation
of muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam that in previous nations
prophets would fill this role but in
this nation
its scholars are the ones who fill that
role of carrying on and preserving
and fighting for the legacy of the
prophet muhammad
unfortunately we are in a time where
we are kind of dipping off and
the practice and righteousness and
veracity and tenacity and tenacity of
the
muslims has has decreased
but this is the nature of this is the
nature of this world
that just as our breath is is the world
it will expand and it will contract
and we happen to be at a time of
contraction
but insha'allah this is not something
that
will last because invariably
that true honor belongs to allah
his messenger and the believers
we will discuss now some of the rulings
with regards to how the prophet
alaihi wasallam would perform
we did discuss this earlier i mentioned
this
i kind of gave us a rundown of this at
the beginning of this chapter
however we will go through what it is
that ibn al-qaeda
will say here for us he says
begins by saying and the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
in the way that he would make salat
there are a variety of ways that he
would perform this prayer
he says minha hada i have a love
of these ways that he would perform with
it is the way that we have just
mentioned
which we mentioned last week that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
would pray three all together when
in in pairs in in units of two
right here
and then he would conclude his
evening of prayer by praying five
consecutive not
sitting for tashahud in any of those
except the final one
so we mentioned he makes eight
in units of two and then he makes five
all together not sitting for teshahood
except in the fifth raka
when he
[Silence]
another is that he would pray
nine all together
how would he do this he would pray
nine one right after the other
he would sit in the eighth raka as we
mentioned
in this sitting position after the
eighth
between the eighth and the ninth he
would remember allah
praise allah ask of allah
and then he would stand up for the ninth
not making taslim
he would then pray the ninth and he
would conclude the ninth
raka by sitting for tashahud and making
taslim
as usual after which he would pray to
raka after he had made tesleem
these two deca are somewhat anomalous to
many scholars
he would pray the witter and
he had encouraged that a person's last
prayer throughout the night be witter
right so what are these two
raqqa that he would pray and in some
narrations he would pray them sitting
down
as he's sitting he would just pray them
in that way
standing up for and sujud but sitting
for the standing
portion some scholars mention that these
are the two
of fajr and that's maybe more accurate
and closer
and there are other exceptions
however
the point is is that we have a principle
in in fick that we need to understand
and these principles are set up not
because
they are designed to avoid understanding
but
to guide a person when they are unable
to understand
right and so we have two issues that
arise
we have the statement of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and then we have the action of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
these two conflict it happens
occasionally now why are they
conflicting
the person is unable to know why they
are conflicting
until they are able to uncover the
reason behind that
there is a principle that guides us and
that is
if the
actions of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam clash with a statement of his
then we take his statement
over his actions
so for example i'll give you one example
of this
there is a narration in which the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
prohibits
that a person relieve himself
relieve herself facing the qibla
that is impermissible for a person to
relieve himself facing the qibla
or with his back to the qibla
this is a statement that he made to the
companions
and what is apparent is that this is
whether a person is relieving himself
outdoors or indoors where there are
walls
right and so the companions the majority
of the companions understood this
narration in this capacity
but there is another narration also
collected in a sahih
that abdullah bin umar observed the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam by
accident while he was relieving himself
behind a wall with his back towards the
qibla
even omar had climbed up on top of a
building on top of a house
and he happened he didn't know he looked
down there was the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
relieving himself behind
relieving himself with his back towards
the qibla and there being a wall
between himself and the qibla so now we
have the statement of the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam telling us do
not do this
and then we have the action of him doing
it right
how are we to understand and harmonize
between these two contradictions
this is something rare but
we take these statements because the
statement could not have been accidental
it is more explicit right logically
a statement is more explicit
an action is less explicit
explicit it is more ambiguous why
because it could be something specific
to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
or he could have forgotten which is most
likely the instance here
or he could have become
momentarily confused as to the direction
or there are other circumstances which
forced him to do something
that he would not naturally do and so
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
relieving himself in this way
in such a private place and accidentally
being seen by ibn omar
we can surmise from these circumstances
that he did not intend
to be followed in this
capacity right
but when he said when you relieve
yourselves
do not relieve yourselves towards the
qibla
or away from the qibla rather relieve
yourselves to the east or to the west
this is based on where medina was
at the time located from the kaaba
and so because if you are in medina the
kaaba would be southern in this
not directly south but a little bit
southeast but nonetheless south
and so this is what we
follow and as for that anomalous
incident this is something that
is is ambiguous to us we aren't sure
what exactly
occurred and so we did not count it in
that respect
this is a general rule and this helps us
to navigate through
the enormous amount of sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
because the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said as we
had read a few chapters ago that
abnormal claim quotes him when he says
i am just a human being as you all are
human beings i am prone to forgetfulness
as you
all are and so these are this is one
principle that is very important for us
to understand
and that is the statement of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is for
us and the actions of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
are for him if they
are if we are unable to harmonize
between the two
he says
he said in another way that he was
narrated to have
praised is that he would pray
seven rakah in the way that he prayed
the nine so he would pray he would sit
in the sixth
rakah and then he would stand for the
seventh and finish
then he would pray to raka sitting down
what is this too again this is an issue
of debate amongst the scholars
of filk
and one of the ways that he would also
pray and perhaps the most common way
that he would pray
is that he would pray the night prayer
in units of two and then he would pray
with it three rakah
and not make any distinction between the
three meaning he would not sit for
tashahud in the second
we do in salah tillman this is
incorrect
if you're going to make witar it should
not be magdeb it should be
three consecutive and then
at the very end
of
[Silence]
mentions one final thing and that is
making sure
all three together in the way that we
just mentioned
this is a difference of opinion amongst
the scholars
and here
mentions that the best opinion
is that he would not make it in this way
rather that he may sit in the second
weka
however he does mention a narration here
collected by
in his sunan and
it's important for us to know that
is considered one of the very strict
scholars of hadith
when he authenticates an erasion the
authentication is to be taken into
serious consideration
because he is considered to be very
strict
in what he considers to be authentic
he mentions the narration on the
authority of ibe
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
was narrated to have said do not
praise soil till witter three rather
praise in a unit of five or seven
and do not make your wither similar to
and so here we have we are
getting an image here in our minds as to
how it is the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make salah
there are a number of ways let us review
the way is that are permissible number
one he would make whitter
as one so he would make two two two
until he makes ten right and then he
would
finish whatever that is with one
independent
this is whitter number two is that he
would make
make salat al-witter in three
and not sit for the except at the very
end
other scholars view that he would sit
for tashahud in the second and third
prayer
however as we mentioned this is
less correct
the third type of witar is that he would
pray five
altogether not making tashahud except in
the fifth
another type is that he would pray seven
altogether
sitting for tashahud in the sixth and
the seventh
rakah and the final way
is that he would make nine rakah all
together
sitting for teshahood in the eighth and
in the ninth
these are the ways that were narrated
inshallah authentically as to how the
prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make sure
traditionally
[Silence]
when we speak about a nasa rahimahullah
and has two books that are
he's most known for right
he has two books which he is most known
for
with
m
[Silence]
he has many books that he wrote but the
two most important
is that he wrote a book called asunan
al-kubra
this is a very illustrious and long
book collecting many narrations of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and it's a very expansive book
and it's a less known book
amongst the broader masses of muslims
it's a book that he had originally
written documenting the majority
of what had reached him of the
narrations of the prophet
alaihi wasallam and then he summarized
this book
into a book referred to as al mujtaba
al mujtaba meaning the
abridged version chosen
select narrations from his book
when we see in the islamic library
the six books of hadith
right we're talking about bukhari muslim
abu dhabi these are the six
that many scholars it's originally
the
to make these six books the main
references
however these six books
which you'll find in bookstores just
written that sunan anna say
right sunin which you'll find commonly
in bookstores and
considered as one of the six books of
hadith this is the summarized version
this is
right the original book
and so this is correct the scholars when
they refer to as sunan
they're speaking about the summarized
version
and when they refer to you
the original text they will say al-qubra
right so that we know which book here
they're talking about
and so sometimes people will read well
it's reported by a nasa if
they'll go back to el mujtaba and not
find the narration
of course you won't find the narration
because that is a different
book it is a different book
he says there is a narration on the
authority of hadefa collected by
nasa's
[Silence]
and so in this narration it's mentioned
that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam did not make with it in
this particular instance he was praying
in ramadan
and udaifu was praying alongside him
that he made for raqqa
and that he did not make s
came to him and
mentioned that it was time to lead
people in salat al-fajr
what does this mean again an isolated
incident this doesn't mean that
he intended necessarily not to make
witar but anything could have happened
he could have not known that it was so
late
or it could be that he had prayed with
him
earlier or a number of things so this is
one
anomalous incident in which he did not
make salah
however whether this was intentional or
unintentional
is something that is left to debate
if not says
and when we collect all the narrations
we see that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was narrated to have
made salat
at the beginning of the evening meaning
right after isha
in the middle of the evening meaning the
middle of the night
and as well at the end of the night
meaning just before fajr all three of
these times he was narrated to have made
salat in witter so we see that
it is the time for winter the proper
time for with it extends
from right after isha until the then of
fajr
[Silence]
it has also been narrated that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam spent
the entirety of his prayer
at one night reciting only one verse
meaning in addition to surat al-fatiha
but he would recite this verse which is
the one hundred
and eighteenth verse of surah tillman
the fifth chapter of the quran this is
again not something to be taken as
a sunnah is it the sunnah for a person
to
pray all night reciting this one verse
no
this is not something that we have that
the companions
did they did not understand it in this
way and the one who narrated this
is we don't have her praying in this way
either
rather it's to be understood that this
is an isolated incident that is
particular to the prophet
s
[Silence]
goes into exactly the positions that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would be in in
when he would praise the
the nighttime prayer he says
three ways that he would most usually
pray
at night he says the first type
and it is the most common way that he
salallahu alaihi wasallam would pray
the night prayer is that he would pray
standing
what does that mean standing just like
we pray normally
you know for the recitation part he
would stand and then he would make roku
and then he would stand up again and
make sujud etc etc
this is the most common way that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
pray
the second is that he would pray sitting
down
what does that mean meaning that instead
of
standing during the standing position
he would sit down and when time for
rokur would come he would stand
up and make rukur and then go through
the motions
but instead of standing he would sit so
he would not
stand he would sit
there is a third type he says
that he would pray and he would recite
the quran in the sitting position
and when there was only a little bit
left for that position which he had
planned to pray
he would stand up recite a little bit
more
and then he would make roku and go
through
normally
sallam
so what does this mean well
it is an obligation
for a person to pray standing up if he
is able
allah subhanahu wa says
and stand in prayer and in diligent
obedience
and the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam would always
pray the obligatory prayer standing
up unless he was unable to do so
this is something that i want to mention
because a lot of people confuse these
things
we have the obligatory prayer
and then we have the prayer which is
mustahab
it is something which is not binding
it's not wedge
it's not obligatory it is preferable
it is encouraged it is
acceptable it is not something which is
binding a person is not going to be held
accountable for failing to make this
prayer
which is anything but the five prayers
and some others mention
specifically according to
different opinions
and so if a person is going to make the
five
prayers and he is able to stand
and he must pray standing
this is considered a pillar of prayer
the scholars of islam mention fourteen
pillars of prayer
the first of which is takbir
the second of which is standing
while others mention standing first as
the first pillar of
salah meaning if a person is able to
stand
and pray the obligatory prayer and does
not without a valid excuse then that
prayer
is deemed invalid
this is important because people play
around with this a lot
they may they have read or heard
narrations of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam standing
praying sitting down
and they will then pray sitting down
with the slightest of discomforts
say a person is in a
public place they're kind of embarrassed
to pray so they just pray sitting down
or a person is driving they don't want
to stop they don't want to pull over
right so they just pray in the car
this is invalid this is unacceptable
the prayer cannot be accepted in this
way if a person is able to stand
standing is an obligation
it is integral to the validity of the
prayer there are instances when a person
may pray sitting down
because of some necessity meaning they
are
unable to stand
this is taken from the narration of
one of the companions
he says
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam told him
and he was suffering from a very serious
bout of hemorrhoids
and so the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said to him
so
he said pray standing unless you are
unable to do so
if you are unable to stand and pray
sitting
and if you are unable to pray sitting
then pray on your side
and so this companion
was suffering from a medical condition
that would make it extremely painful
for him to stand while he is praying
and this is not a
static ruling meaning that a person may
have a condition
where his leg locks up or whatever it is
okay
they're unable to pray standing
sometimes they can pray standing it
comes and goes
right then a person must pray based on
based on their ability at each and every
prayer it's not just
i pray sitting all the time and that's
it if a person is
able to stand on certain occasions
then the person is to pray in the
standing position
etcetera etcetera therefore it's
important for us to understand the
sunnah as it properly is
that an individual is to pray standing
up
if there is a reason why a person is
just physically unable to stand
meaning that a person is in an airplane
and there is absolutely no place to
stand to pray
a person is in a bus that will not stop
and it will
end with them missing the time of prayer
for instance
then in this case they pray sitting down
in the position they are able to pray in
if they're in a moving
vehicle a bus for instance
and they have to pray sitting down they
should wait until the bus faces towards
the qibla
they should then make their tech beer to
initiate prayer
and then they are and then they are to
pray normally even if the bus changes
directions for instance from the qibla
they do not have to
change their direction
likewise if a person prays in the
sitting position
for standing they should
stand
if they're able to do so some people are
just unable to pray standing
but they can make rukur they can make
sujud
or they can make one of the two and this
is all based on the
principle
muslim the prophet salallahu
anything i have commanded you all do of
it as much as
you are able so if a person is able to
make sujud but he's not able to make
roku
then he is to make sujud and
rukur should be in the sitting position
the only time that a person has the
discretion
to pray sitting down completely
not making sujud is in the sunnah prayer
a prayer that is not obligatory this is
something that the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam would do in his travels
as mentioned by ibn umar
that the prophet occasionally
pray on his camel or
whatever it is that he was writing and
he would
make sujud by bowing forward and leaning
forward
this is for the night prayer this is not
for the obligatory prayer
and even if a person prays in the
sitting position in the obligatory
prayer
then he must make rook
[Silence]
my
you